you talk about how [ __ ] crazy it is
like meeting people who watch your
videos it's so [ __ ] surreal
i never get used to it i'm like
now i have like like a conditioned
response that i could be like okay this
is how i should respond to like
activating execution 101. but that's why
mcdonald's smile but that's why getting
recognized anybody
anywhere but conventions you're so
unprepared
because you just i just you just never
get used to that feeling because i'm
just like
man i'm just a [ __ ] dude who talks
about anime online i mean it's already
surprising when people have conventions
like come up to you and recognize you
but what's weirder is where you're like
nowhere near a [ __ ] convention and
it's just like a random like
guy or girl who's just sees like that
[ __ ] dude in singapore oh my god
oh my god yeah you can tell us
okay so we we were at a singapore
convention i think it was uh
anime what was it called anime festival
asia or something like that
afa we have a afa singapore um and we
were we were in this
we we were outside the convention we're
like getting lunch or something it was
me
sydney and joey i believe and alan i
think and alan and alan yes
so there were four of us there and we
were just walking um in one of the
in just like this random shopping mall
and then
we just hear this screech this is like
this is like
this is like the loudest screech i've
ever heard in my life like a banshee
screech
like you would have thought you would
have thought like someone came through
with like a truck and it was like
running people over yeah exactly and it
immediately triggered my flight or
flight uh fight or flights
like instincts right everybody turned
around what the hell what the [ __ ]
going on
and all we see is this [ __ ] kid
bolting it towards joey
right and i'm like and like time just
[ __ ] stopped at that moment i'm like
am i about to witness my [ __ ] friend
die in front of my
eyes is he about to get stabbed or
something
he's like the dude was like full of like
assassins creeding me
like just [ __ ] like low as [ __ ] like
running towards me through this giant
crowd and as the crowd is partying you
can see this kid just coming straight
i'm like
oh he's coming for me i'm gonna die like
because and because he's like he's like
naruto running almost i can't see his
hands right so i'm like
this guy's probably got a knife he's
about to stab me yeah
so this so i'm just prepared to die he
stops like right here he just screeches
to a halt and he says
i love you joey
[Laughter]
meanwhile poop is falling out of my
pants meanwhile we're just like
oh okay joey's not dead okay ah
oh well what was that terrifying
can you take a photo of me i'm like yeah
yeah
please did like felix say one time like
southeast asian fans like the craziest
yeah they are in public they
just scream absolutely shout out to the
southeast asians
the afa was great it's it's on like a
whole different level
from like any like any convention
in america like i um i remember watching
joey walk from one panel to another
it was basically it was basically like
watching justin bieber walk through like
like a pre that's gotta be an ego boost
though it felt pretty good
not gonna lie i love it when you're just
like chilling and then like someone in
the line there she's like
yeah he's like yeah yeah i think as well
like it might have been because like
that singapore afa was it was a it was a
first for that convention for a lot of
reasons
because i think i was like the first
youtuber that had ever been invited
yeah and also i was the first ever guest
at that convention that didn't charge
for signatures
yeah and like because like i remember
when i was sitting there like waiting
the staff was like
all right so uh tell me uh how much do
the signings cost
like what are you talking about it's
like how much do they call it like five
dollars ten dollars how much
so that i can tell people in the line
i'm like it's free
and like all right what do you mean yeah
he was like
what what what do you mean yeah it means
free they couldn't process it
process it they're like what do you mean
it's free and i'm like yeah it's [ __ ]
freaking i've heard like some other
guests get annoyed when
youtubers turn up and don't charge
because they're like well you're just
devaluing you're making us look like
ripoffs and i'm like well
yeah it's just like if i'm selling
something like a print or something
they're like
yeah but that's the thing right i was
selling prints because i was doing a
collab with like
studios right so it's like people can
just [ __ ] buy this yeah i feel like
if they
like i shouldn't charge someone to sign
something they already paid the entrance
fee together yeah exactly
yeah exactly exactly and they're like
already buying like the merch that i
collaborate with right so it's like i'm
not going to charge them anymore
when you see this like [ __ ] like it's
like the guy who sneezed on set on star
wars charged 50
and it's like
who the [ __ ] are you i just i really
disagree with them doing that and they
charge so much i really hate it like
it's so cool give them something
physical right yeah exactly like this
should be
like an item my signature should not be
worth money no
i don't know it should be like a nice
little memorabilia
but i don't know anyone i think it
completely destroys the meaning of a
signature right like from a famous
person in my opinion
i don't know i i would just i just feel
bad charging me too i think this [ __ ]
off i'm like the greatest [ __ ] like
like the the worst i could i would i
would get away with
is you know charging i haven't even like
charged for prints or anything like that
because i've never done principle
or like to paint a sort out yeah it's
it's a pain to sort out but at least
give them something physical right
that's what i said exactly exactly if if
you know we need to do something
right right but again like we're doing
well enough for ourselves like i'm not
that [ __ ] desperate to be like i have
500 prints they all need to go
i guess sometimes the conventions can't
really like like pay you much for your
time so it's like i get it that some
people want to like me oh yeah
you know link i'm going but you know
like that's not really the reason i go
to canada no no no true
i just want to [ __ ] meet my fans any
conventions of southeast asia want to
invite us
any conventions in general please any
conventions in general we [ __ ] love
conventions so much
we miss it so much after this [ __ ]
drought of conventions we really need